this is a vr chat talent show and
whoever has the best talent wins
fifty thousand dollars that's a whole
lot of cheddar
yeah bring out the first contestants
andy slayers oh my god he's so sparkly
what's up guys 50 000 is on the line
show us what you got
hate when that happens
whoa let's go
let's go mr slayer do you actually have
a guitar with you in real life
in real life yeah yeah yo fist bump me
dog
chris yes or no yes i give him a yes
i give him a yes
yes that's four yeses round two baby
not bad for a first contestant bring out
the next one
darren zeus someone here
is copying another uh it's a yes for me
i don't care what this town is
these boxes i have hidden the keys of
this
mr beast custom made lamborghini each
one of you can choose
a box i pick crate number one three
crate number three
two three since your majority vote goes
to number three i am opening number
three for you guys
no oh we got no no
oh my god you chose the wrong box
of course because it's in number one i
was correct show us
you got stick bugs baby
it's in none of the cases you're a
scammer mr beast would never
scam anybody chris go ahead and rate it
no well i'm giving it a yes and i'm
changing his note to a yes
quackity what do you rate it you did not
give me a tesla like i hoped you would
so it's a no from me
i'm changing his note 2 yes as well well
three yeses in a row
carl what do you rate it i'm giving it a
no because his skin is ugly
all right i'm just gonna leave jimmy no
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine get out of here you've upset
jimmy
you lose next contestant
joe swanson oh wait really quick really
quick
oh my god oh my god
peter hello peter turmitsu just so you
understand
50 000 is on the line here okay
show us what you got beer i can't take
it anymore
bonnie's always messing with other guys
because i don't have legs
but the secret is i could stand
totally i'm an anime waifu peter
not gonna lie you're gonna have to blow
my mind the next 10 seconds or it's
probably a no for me
oh my god i'm so thirsty i turn into a
bidding machine peter
maybe it's because i didn't see the show
but i'm giving it a note
i'm gonna give it a you had water in
your vending machine so it's a no for me
i'm giving it a note because i have seen
the show all right next contestant
what up gamers before you do your talent
i i see my logo that's a yes for me all
right continue
do you want a close-up because i got
more drip here then oh snap
what look at that i'm taking chris's
vote and i'm also making that a yes
i'm not mr b so you haven't impressed me
yet i'm gonna show
you the most expensive avatar in vr chat
and
my random subscriber's gonna help me
with it oh hello there
what the hell is that what is that
nothing says get out of my swamp
like this oh that's the skin that's an
ogre exaggeration
oh god all right chris i'm giving you
your your
vote back this is beautiful this is
everything you need
this is an eyesore chris what's your
vote that's a no from me this is a
hell no for me yeah here i'm just gonna
give a note for everybody i'm sorry
we like your skin though thank you do
you hey hey stay away from stay away
from mr beast
stay away back up
oh what happened to our stage we did
that show us your talent
stand over here please oh my god whoa
whoa
what how did you put this rocket here
for ten dollars i'll put whatever
picture you want on the moon
that yo it's still going oh my goodness
it's all the way up
oh
what are you doing there ah oh what is
that
what is it whoa whoa what the what are
you doing
you're listening
what is this oh it says mungus
oh my god doge is sauce among us
reference
how is this how did oh oh
oh reddish sauce
oh no what
red was impostor guys i get that
reference because i play among us
all right on the count of three everyone
say your vote one two
three that's easy yes yes yes yes you
just got four yeses
which means you are currently tied for
the fifty thousand dollars in cash
wait you're to my left in real life i
know to my right it's been bothering me
the whole thing
quackity you do realize you're in our
studio right what the hell
wait if quackity's to my right
then who is this guy who are you
hey it's that contestant that's been
awkwardly standing there while we talk
about all this nonsense
do your talent so i use a full body
packing
wait how'd you turn into quackity that's
not me
okay now it's me i don't want to watch
this let me know when it's over
jimmy like this is his body doing this
dance all right i'll turn around
oh god jesus
lord yo we should play more vr on this
channel
he's doing this in his room right now
jimmy this man is putting in
effort if you do actually have a full
body suit on
bring your right leg up right oh my god
that's insane do one of those like air
kicks that you did
like okay so we got this
oh my god i'll take it that's a yes yes
yes congratulations on
four yeses what is that thing
what the hell is that lude what is your
talent
i'm gonna do stand-up comedy for y'all
how are you gonna do stand-up comedy
with no legs
yeah you were saying what the hell i'll
tell you he's not winning 50 grand
next guy get in the circle so what i do
is i do a uh
improvise a song based on words so if
you guys could give me like
a couple words to work with i'll make a
song pavement
orange blossom all right make a wrap
let's hear it
[Music]
i got me an itchy
i know what to do i'm gonna rub it
on a pavement or two and probably
get some oranges and take the fields
and put it where i got those itchy feels
i saw blossoms along the way
and i thought that they might do
something for the pain
i got my ears on fire yeah
it's on fire yeah my hair's on fire yeah
whoa
[Music]
why aren't you dancing carl oh i
thought i would get relief but instead
it got worse
i thought
oh it disconnected me oh no
did you think of all that just now uh
yes
all right so chris ray i'm gonna give it
a very
big yes i'm gonna give it a yes wacky do
you vote for you
and carl since carl disconnected so carl
says no i say yes that makes carl a
really bad guy
how could carl do that go look the
raccoon
slash doge guy over there in the eyes
and tell him
no 50 grand for you listen hey hey man i
think it was really good
but carl carl hates animals like you
he stomps on them throws him in the
garbage so that's why he said no
all right i'll see you later thank you
so blame it on carl
come on out whoever's next my animation
involves you guys getting out of your
seats and how do i know i won't die
i promise you won't die it's like middle
school all over again
oh are you going to jump
what bro csi kidnapped by clifford the
big red
oh shut up take this seriously oh wait
there's a backside to this note
it says we can find mr beast at the
mountain we gotta go there
hey yeah that's probably not a good idea
what battle for the beast what's that
over there that white thing
is that a 19 fortnight gift card
stop that's a trap
what's happening oh that was the
no oh no oh
that's oh that's oh my god i play among
us too
oh my god oh
it's turn-based combat i know you're all
here for mr beast
what'd you do with him he's safe with me
and he will stay
the drip kidnapped you i don't know what
i'm watching but it's
gonna be it's perfection that's vine
calculation number
oh my gosh monkey is eating bananas
oh he turned it into team trees oh look
he's got a health bar out there
[Music]
oh hold on
oh my god among us drip grabs monkey
oh no he's turned into minecraft among
us drip does the dance
dude they're all about to die there's no
way they can come back
who is that what oh my gosh
the holy trinity whoa
oh my god it's so close wait they almost
have them oh the kids
oh my god
what did i just witness
[Music]
it's jimmy mr beast is saved that's
insane
i think we can all agree that was the
most epic thing we saw today
that was the most epic thing i've ever
seen i agree
honestly guys i want to see where your
head's at but where my head is is i
think we just give him the 50 grand
right now
i agree he not only deserves 50 grand
he deserves happiness quackity are you
going to rip 50 grand out of another
person's hands
listen listen you got to understand okay
listen
tonight i'm sorry speed but you're going
home with 50 grand
so speed you do realize 50 000
is a lot of money yes good thank you for
watching the video goodbye everyone